και αγνώησε όλα τα άλλα πωαστραβα ρα στηβουλευτικές εκλωίας να επιθανότητες θα που έλε γε
τώρα να βάλο έναστοίχεμα θα σου έλέγανεάλλο θα είναι πρώτον κόμμα ο συναγερμος αλλά να
πρώτον όμαμε είκοσικοσιδύο της εκατό εσυναγερμό από τον τριανταπέντευου τάξεια ας το τριαντα πεντέλα στο
τριάντα έλα στο κοσιοκτώ ο αβέροφνεοφή του έπινενέξω από το δεύτερο γύρων μεκοσ έξικομαγκάτι οιοψηλά
πόσα επιενοσυναγερμός στε τελευταιες επρεκλογίας ράανοσυναγερμός η γεσία η νίναι γεσία το δημοκρατικού συναγερμού και
για να εμαστε δεί και οη μετηνανήταν δεν είναι μονονίαν τα ηγεσία το δημοκρατικο συναγερμού
το μόνο που θα έχει να μας σπείτι ίν επομένι των εκλογόν είναι είμαστε πρώτη
δύναμη αλλά έχουμε κοσιδύο κοτρα της εκατόν σίγουρα θα ακουστούφωνές διαμαρτηρίας προβλέπω ότι ναι θα
γίνει και αφισβείτης η της υγεσίας το ότημένουν στελέχει εκτός κούρσας στελέχει που παραδωσιακάφερνν χιλιάδες
ψύους είναι και αυτό ένα πρόβλημα το οποίο πρααδιαχειριστεί το γόμα της εξιας μην ξεχναμα
ότημένει έξιοχαρις γιοργιάδης αβεροφμειοφιή του νκος τον ναρίτρης ευθυμείος ζήπλαρος ο μπαράδομαυριδή στην κερίνια που
παραδωσιακά έφερναν χιλιδες ψφς ίσως ακινή απόφαση για τρεις ητιας να μηνι να μην βγει
και τόσο στη δεξια ντάξει σίγουρα αλλά από την άλλη για να δούμε το την
άλληνόψυντου νομίσματος αν δεν κάμεις κάτι τόσο ρίζωσπαστικώ να βάλησε ένανόριος σεθητίες σπάνει έχει στην
ανανέωση δηλαδή που τη μια λέμε δεν υπάρχει ανανέωση της πολιτικής ζωής που την άλλη
πολης πλησιάσεη να γίνει η ανανέωση να προσπαθούμε να του κρατήσουμε διότη φερνου ψύφους θεωρώ
ότη το στίχημα της του δημοκρατικού συναεμού σήμερα είναι ένα μπορέσει να δημιουργή η ψηφοδέλτια
τα οποία σίγουρα δε θα μπορούν να φέρουν